in today's morning rounds we are looking
at direct-to-consumer medication
services companies like hems in Rome and
allow people to order prescription drugs
for conditions like hair loss and
erectile dysfunction without seeing a
doctor face to face so you simply pick
out what medicine you want fill out a
questionnaire and then submit it for a
review by the doctor by a doctor rather
after answering about 20 questions one
of our producers was able to order
generic viagra from Roman in a couple of
hours he did not talk with a doctor
about an hour later the drugs had been
shipped Roman sent us a statement saying
Roman is a complement to in-person care
not a replacement
roben enables physicians to easily
connect with patients and offer high
quality and accessible health care for
certain conditions via telemedicine
a hims representative said only a
licensed physician is in the position to
know the risks and benefits of a certain
medication and whether it's the best
option for a patient
we created the hims hers platform to
help make that conversation possible
without judgment or stigmatization dr.
taryn arul is here Tara good morning
good morning it's a medical ethical
ethics professor at NYU calls this
restaurant menu Medicine right why is
that well we are living in a whole new
world where people want things on demand
we want our uber on demand our food on
demand and now we want our prescription
meds on demand and there are companies
that have millions of dollars backing
them saying that this will work because
it's easy it's discreet it's affordable
and it's streamlined and they're betting
on conditions that people want to
maintain privacy around things like
erectile dysfunction things like hair
loss skin care libido and the issue is
that it's really turning the paradigm of
how we've practiced medicine on its head
so in the past it was the doctor
prescribing the doctor diagnosing now
it's the patient self diagnosing and
self-describing with the doctor as a
gateway and at least the doctor has used
to have to see you before the unless you
knew the doctor at least the doctor had
to see you to take a look at you to see
exactly what was going on do you see any
problems with this downsides there's
some definite problems I mean first and
foremost it erodes the whole nature of
the doctor-patient relationship that
trust building time that you have
together to work on things like
prevention for example there's a reason
we call them vital signs there's a
reason we have a physical exam it really
informs us about what we need to be
doing and how to prescribe in addition
people are filling out their information
they're putting in their blood pressure
in their history what if they're not
being so truthful I don't have a medical
record to verify what they're telling me
some of the other concerns are that
problems like erectile dysfunction for
example may just be that but they also
may be indicative of underlying problems
with your arterial disease or diabetes
and so maybe we're missing the boat how
do I verify who the doctor is on the
other side how qualify there where the
meds are coming from are they coming
from China and and also when I get my
medications am I gonna get them with the
important information about how to take
them so some big real concerns around
this and also with a drug like viagra
there are a lot of counter indications
as well right taking those that if
you're just ordering that over the
internet and your doctor doesn't go
through them it risk death I mean these
are prescription meds every single
medicine is biologically active and when
you look them up they have common side
effects rare side effects black box
warnings on certain of them so for
instance things like viagra can cause
low blood pressure sudden vision loss
and hearing loss can you get can you get
antidepressants anti-anxiety drugs from
these same websites yes you can get any
drug well there are certain drugs
they're marketing so for example
propanolol which is a beta blocker
sometimes used for blood pressure
they're marketing in an off-label way
which is for social performance anxiety
and this is one of the issues which is
that drug companies and drug
distributors cannot market off-label it
is legal but these companies are really
getting around they're still flying
under the radar because they're saying
we're not a drug company we're not a
drug they regulate we're a platform you
know they're not regulated I got sick
and there's gonna be a lawsuit
absolutely I mean some of these
antidepressants like zoloft and
wellbutrin come with suicidal ideation
warnings in young populations need to
see your doctor in person yeah there's
an there's a reason why we have a
face-to-face interaction so I'm guessing
you're not a fan I'm very concerned
honest when I read this I was a pretty
alarmed by no concern thank you doctor
Niroula always good to have you here